バイバイこんにちははじめ社長です私今
東京のボスにいるんですけれども本日もう
超ビッグイベント来ております
ベイブレードの超大型大会でございます
[音楽]
新しいベビルドXっていうシリーズが
始まってなんかね今大きい大会が開かれて
て今日初めての動画が来てるのが
エクストリームカップg2東京っていう
東京での超大型のベイブレード大会に来て
おります
参加人数なんと250人超え
すごくない
めっちゃ多い250人が集まって今から1
位を決めるわけよそれに私はじめ社長も
参加させていただきますいや多分ねもう
本当にさっきバート会場見てきたんです
けれどもちっちゃいお子さん小学生の人も
いたしもう大きなお友達
あのーおじさん言い方を選ばせるとおじ
さんみたいな人もいましたもうガチ勢ね
ガツガツにやってる大人も子供も集まって
みんなで今から戦うわけなんですけれども
そこに私も参加させていただきますすごく
ない
かっこいい
さすがに行きますか
このように行きたいところだうわぁ
[音楽]
失礼します
これが多分ないと出れないんですよね今日
はこんな感じでベイブレードのバカでかい
多分最大規模かな今までのこの大会で優勝
したらトリマー日本一なんじゃないかって
ぐらいのでかい生き物大会です
頑張っていきます
はじめさんどんなベイブレード使うんです
か僕ですか
公式の大会って予選はちょっとわからない
んですけども多分本線まで行くとベベルと
3つで戦うんですよ
3つ一応準備しときたいなと思いまして
とりあえず全部持ってきた1回全部
とりあえず今僕が持ってるのは全部持って
きましたとこの中からどれで戦うかをある
程度決めてるんですけどもちょっと選んで
いきたいと思いますどうするかなぁ全然
主人公使ってるドランスソード俺絶対入れ
たいのよめっちゃかっこよくこれ超攻撃型
のドランスドーザー俺これは使います1回
力押しで勝ちたいという気持ちがあるので
なるほどでもう一つがこのヘルズサイズで
下がボールっていうこの丸くなってるやつ
が
めっちゃ強いって
ネットで見ました
ネットの通りに作ってみたのでちょっと
これは入れたいかな
もう1個が悩んでるんだよねどうしよう
どうしよう
トランザ行くか
ないだろう
わかんないワンちゃんあるかもしれない
けどね
どうするかな今時給と
攻撃
[音楽]
迷うなぁでもやっぱ長く回ってるのが絶対
強いからなぁマジでパーツ
パーツ選びなんだけどここから両方一緒
えどうしようどうしよう
[音楽]
守りに入りたくないよね
締め切りだよね
色がなちょっとやだななんかどうせだっ
たらさ
信号機みたいな色にしたじゃんとなると
もう次選ぶの黄色しかないんだよないや
迷うなOkOk見えた見えた俺も決めた
こうしてこれでいくわもうディフェンス
タイプ1回守り抜きたいっていう気持ち
この3つでどうでしょうこれこれで行くわ
いろんなバランスめっちゃ良くないいい
ですね予選1個だけで戦うんかなわかん
ないけど1個だけだったらもう普通にあの
環境トップで行かせていただきます大人気
ないいや言うてガチバトルなんでねもう
このベイブレードの世界は大人の子供も
関係に俺は誰が声と全力で戦いますよでは
予選一匹いきます
もうちょっとあの
練習してちょっとどれがいいか決めたいと
思います
時間あるからね予選までちょっといい
組み合わせ連れて探します
[音楽]
練習だから
お願いしますはい次32まず全く一緒一緒
Lサイズ
[音楽]
俺
負けた予選が1個で戦うのでまずどれで
戦うか決めたいと思います予選今んとこ
候補これです下がちょっとボール状のやつ
これがね
強いんですよ
[音楽]
でネットで言われてました
ですか
おーい
何してんだろう
[音楽]
オープニングみたいな始まってますね
きっとカジュアルがいろんなところに設置
されてますさあもうすぐ大会が始まりそう
です
飛んでおりますすごいなぁ
始まる直前です
[音楽]
2023予選第1回戦行く
ぞー
[音楽]
気持ちが決まったね
というわけでそろそろ呼ばれそうです僕
256番
[音楽]
俺だ行ってきます
入り口から入って待機列に並んでくれ
やばい緊張してきた
年齢層すごいね
もう子供から大人まで
なんか誰でもいるな女性は1個だけなので
これでバレるなやばい
そっかここからもう始まってるわけです
もんね戦いが見られると対策されるから
まだ見てないです
緊張しますけど
素敵なんだよな
みんないい人だけど敵なんだよな
倒すしかない
勝ったらこれしていいお願いします
大丈夫ですか
[音楽]
大丈夫だよ
行きます
[音楽]
はいここからは会場の音がちょっと
大きかったので私の実況でお送りさせて
いただきますよろしくお願いしますまずは
相手選手の確認僕の対戦相手はこちらの
男の子
身長差がかなりありますね
身長差約3メートルといったところ
でしょうかこれ場所決めじゃんけんです
勝ったら場所が決められる結構右が左側で
大事買ったここは大人気なく僕の有利な
ところを狙いに行きますこちらですねはい
もう大人も子供も関係ないのでマジで勝ち
に行きますそして使えるエネルギーを1個
出してくださいというジャッジからの指示
がありましたえー
徹底して後ろを向く音投げない決して相手
にはビビるの見せないそしてこのビデオで
行くというのが決まりましたねはいまだ
相手が何を使うかも分かりませんが決め
ましたでせーので何を使うか出すという
感じですせーのはい
僕のは赤い色そして相手選手のは青はい
はじめしゃちょーのレベルではあんたと
いうことを覚えておいてくださいそして
シューターも回収されて今からジャッジが
ですね不正してないかとかしっかりと時間
をかけて確認していただきます
緊張してるね俺こう物と物を使うバトルな
のでこうずるできないかとか不正がないか
とかをかなり
精密に見ていただきましたはい特に問題
なかったということで
各々のベイブレードとシュートを返して
もらいますはいちょっと入ってきましたね
でえっとベベレードお取りくださいという
ことなんですけどもジャッジが作るので
なんか自分たちで組み立てろとはい自分
たちで組み立てて特に問題ないかという
ことを今見てますね
これねお互いビビると組み立てれば
いよいよバトル開始ですはいでここからは
もうジャッジ関係なく
何かあったら2人の責任なのでもう自己
責任でお願いしますということでお互い
目視で確認して料理バトル始まります一応
ルールとしては4ポイント先に4ポイント
取れば勝ちです一番いい勝ち方すれば3
ポイント取れますで今そのバトルが終わっ
てもベイブレードを触らないでとかそう
いうこういろいろ
ルールを説明してもらってますはいそして
もう始まりますよこれついについに1回戦
はじめしゃちょーの予選が始まります
セット321Gさあ始まりました赤色が
はじめしゃちょ青が開いている選手の
インスタグラお互い悪くなあれ
飛んでったー
3ポイントですはい
説明しましょうベイブレード勝ち方が4つ
あります1つがスピンフィニッシュ
ベイブレードの回転が0になります
止まったら1ポイントゲットです
バーストフィニッシュベイブレードパーツ
がボカーンてあのー
ぶっ飛んでいくことがありますパーツが
ぶっ飛んでいくと2ポイントゲットそして
2つなんか落ちてはいけない場所があるん
ですけどもそこに飛ばされると2ポイント
そしてエクストリームフィニッシュこの
場所下のこの場所
緑色にかっこいいじゃない部分から飛び出
てしまった時だけ最悪の負け方3ポイント
取られてしまいます今僕3ポイント取られ
ました
さあもう完全に後がなくなってしまった
はじめ社長も何でも1ポイント取られた
瞬間向こうが4000になった時点で僕の
負けですもう
負けられない321
シュート大人の意地を見せてくれ悪くない
スタートお互いいい感じに競り合ってます
がどうだ他のキャラクターあー
[音楽]
お取りください
では
リストバンド
に0対6で負けました